У військовій формі ЗСУ Сергій Мокренюк прийшов на особливе для нього місце
- на київський Майдан Незалежності.
Сергій – активіст та правозахисник.
У 2013 разом із тисячами мітингувальників Євромайдану він почав боротьбу за зміни в Україні.
Тут наш табір стояв. Тут було перегороджено. Тут все були барикади. Неймовірна кількість людей!
Втім, історія Сергія почалася зовсім не тут, а у рідному Криму.
Листопад 2013. Звідси Сергій починає відлік подій, яких не очікував ні він, ні самі кримці, каже він.
Однак Росія завжди готувалася до окупації півострова.
І тоді – в часи, коли українці на протестах у Києві та у Криму, де був Сергій,
обирають курс на євроінтеграцію, російська пропаганда переходить до дій.
Інформаційний простір був захоплений, власне, тими, хто був із грошима.
На той момент це була "Партія регіонів".
Мені дзвонить один з журналістів, каже мені: "О, слухай, ти ж був на Майдані,
ми якраз програму робимо, то, може, ти прийдеш і розкажеш?".
І от така тема: "Крим: чи можливе повернення до Конституції 1991 року?"
Я розумію, що ця програма була, це така підготовка.
Сергій разом з активістами Андрієм Ковальським, Андрієм Щекуном
та Ісмаїлом Ісмаїловим щоденно організовували мирні акції у Феодосії та Сімферополі,
куди приїздили тисячі українців з усього півострова.
Перед псевдореферендумом на півострові Сергія та інших активістів, як розказує чоловік,
почали переслідувати, палити їх автівки,
а на самого Сергія та його жінку і дітей одного разу напали на вулиці.
9 березня ми в Сімферополі проводили акцію,
формально вона була присвячена 200-річчю Тараса Шевченка,
а реально вона була зібрана під лозунгами за Соборну Україну, за суверенітет.
Туди приїхало досить багато людей, десь близько двох з половиною тисяч.
Саме в цей день зранку росіяни викрали Андрія Щекуна і Анатолія Ковальського,
на той момент я мав розмову з представниками Меджлісу,
сказав, що ми будемо блокувати дорогу для того,
щоб вимагати, щоб звільнили Щекуна і Ковальського.
Проте представники Меджлісу просили цього категорично не робити.
Я зрозумів, якщо ми вже не готові до таких простих дій, як перекриття дороги,
то нема шансів щось швидко вирішити або зробити.
Я виїхав з Криму 10 березня 2014 року.
На питання як сталося так, що Росія змогла окупувати півострів в 2014 році,
Сергій Мокренюк сьогодні відповідає так –
тоді народ не був готовий боротися, а зрадників не було кому зупинити.
Люди, які вчиняли державну зраду, розраховувалися годинами!
Що це було? Окремі люди активно проявляли свою позицію,
а окремі повністю працювали на росіян,
дехто був з самого початку завербований росіянами.
Хто більше вкладав ресурсів, той там і переміг,
це боротьба між державами була в довгу конструкцію,
росіяни на той момент виграли.
Але це тактична перемога, не стратегічна.
З моменту виїзду з півострова Сергій документує злочини росіян на півострові,
працює над розробкою санкційних законопроєктів проти РФ
та тримає зв'язок з групами кримських партизанів.
Ця робота не припиняється досі, каже Сергій,
навіть після того, як 24 лютого 2022 він вступив до лав ЗСУ.
Ті люди, які там кожен день щось роблять для того, щоб Росія не з’їла Крим до кінця,
вони борються, це боротьба, вона різна, різні форми, але я точно можу стверджувати,
що Росія ще не перетравила Крим.
Відкусити – відкусила, гризти – погризла, але не перетравила.
Сьогодні Сергій тримає зв'язок зі колишніми активістами кримського та київського Майдану,
чимало з яких разом із ним нині в лавах Збройних Сил.
Усі вони налаштовані рішуче звільняти українські землі – кожен на своєму бойовому напрямку.
Сергій Мокренюк певен: його Крим вже цьогоріч повернуть під контроль України,
бо держава переосмислила підхід до його звільнення.
Я був впевнений, що дипломатичний шлях є одним з інструментів, який можливий.
Але, на мою думку, ми не використовували його повною мірою.
Елементарне: у 2014 році Крим був окупований, а санкції за Крим були застосовані тільки в 2019.
Перемога для Криму – це звільнення абсолютно всіх територій України.
Ще багато років тому я озвучив сценарій звільнення Криму,
він був дуже простий: в один день вони просто звідти втечуть!
Наостанок Сергій ділиться із нами мрією –
показати свою малу Батьківщину дітям, які в часи окупації Криму були ще дуже малі
і нічого не пам’ятають про Феодосію.
А ще – нарешті побачитися з батьками,
з якими протягом більш як року немає жодного зв’язку.